good morning the graduates of 2016
congratulations now to honor your
extraordinary achievements I would like
to take this opportunity to be
thoughtful reflective and wise but
seeing the look on your faces right now
perhaps I should just aspire to be brief
to everyone who has come here this
morning to celebrate our graduates
welcome to MIT and to celebrate the
parents and families of today's
graduates I want to call out one story
in particular when Joe Bellantoni
[Applause]
when Joe Bellantoni began the Executive
MBA program at MIT Sloan he was excited
like all of his classmates but he faced
an extra challenge because since a car
accident in 2007 Joe has been blind he
graduates today thanks to his own
intelligence confidence and
determination and thanks to the fact
that his wife Denise chose the knees
chose to be with him every step of the
way attending his study groups and
typing all of his assignment succeeding
at MIT is a serious challenge for
everyone facing that challenge while
also coping with any form of disability
as many of our students do is a triumph
so to all the graduates family and
friends with us today your story may or
may not be as dramatic but we know that
this day is the joyful result of years
of effort loving support and sacrifice
please accept our deepest admiration and
gratitude
[Applause]
it's great to have all of you here in
Killian Court on this wonderful day for
this tremendously important occasion my
job two days to deliver I charge the
graduate and I'll get to that in a
minute but first let me begin with a
question how many of you are graduating
seniors raise your hands make some noise
[Applause]
well since you entered MIP in September
2012 and I started my job in july two
thousand twelve you are the first class
that i have observed all the way from
convocation to commencement let me just
say you've been magnificent company but
that coincidence of timing also means
that we have something profound in
common we were freshmen together as I
expect you will recall that first year
was not easy although unlike me you got
to enjoy the option of pass no record
that first winter many of you had a
snowball fight right here on Killian
Court I accepted the challenge to join
and I got creamed as we progress to our
time here we started to figure things
out we passed a lot of tests we help
each other deal with some tragic losses
we face some hard facts about our
community and work together to make
things better somewhere in the middle
for reasons I cannot explain a few of us
got ice buckets down on her head
although that became great training for
last year when we got dumped on us
unlimited buckets of snow through it all
all of us got much sleep and we got a
few more grey hairs Oh actually that was
just me and then a month ago we proved
that among the many important things we
know how to do here at MIT we know how
to party so we have a lot in common
except for one thing unlike me you
finished all of your problem set so
unlike me you get to leave of course
this applies not just the seniors but to
all of you who will receiving diplomas
today you are now prepared to depart
each of you in search of your own MIT
like exoplanet that could potentially
support life as we know it at MIT let me
alert you MIT like exoplanets may feel a
hundred million miles away you might
even feel as if you've just been
abandoned on Mars but assuming assuming
you will encounter signs of intelligent
life I expect you may have to explain
what life is like back on Planet MIT so
let me offer a few pointers to get you
started you can tell them that on
pluggin MIT we love heart problems and
we know that if you are working alone
you're most likely doing it wrong for
instance when an MIT scientists let a 30
year effort that produce the first
direct evidence of gravitational waves
those ripples those ripples in
space-time that Einstein predicted he
could have done a mic drop instead he
went out of this way to share the credit
with a more than 1,000 other scientists
on the team
from dozens of institutions because in
his words that's the way that physics
gets done on planet mit we love data we
just love it in fact that's one of you
out there proof beyond a polka-dotted
out we even love ridiculous data about
campus strength in the color of
underwear but mostly we love data
because it helps us understand the world
understand poverty and cancer and the
fresh water crisis and climate change in
short it helps us understand how we can
make the world better on planet MIT were
being called a nerd will always be a
compliment we're working very hard on
inventing the future and if you think I
may be exaggerating some of today's
graduates recently won first prize in
the first prize in the Hyperloop
challenge they design a futuristic pot
that could transport passengers from
city to city through special tubes at
750 miles an hour and in fact you and
your pet robotic cheetah will be able to
climb into one of those yourself around
the time you're ready to trade in your
driverless car and I hope and I hope you
will also tell people that on planet MIP
we celebrate mine and him and heart
every daily members of our community
commit random acts of kindness and
thanks to the leadership of many of
today's graduates we are making sure
that MIT practices systemic acts of
kindness and inclusion
to mine and hen and heart I hope you
remember that one because iron men may
have gone to MIT but the truth is none
of us none of us is Ironmen with
professors you her and David Newman I
bet we could make a pretty impressive
suit of armor but none of us has a suit
of armor strong enough to get us through
this life alone what saves us in the end
is hard as you go out into the world
heart is what makes the heart problems
worth solving hard is what makes the
data sing with meaning heart is your
best blueprint as you invent the future
and when sometimes you find yourself
adrift in deep space it'll be a human
connection hand to hand and heart to
heart that will bring you home safe
those of you graduating today
experienced a remarkable period in MIT
history it included terrible pain and
loss fortunately it also included an
exceptional sense of community and
compassion and shed progress enjoy that
feeling of connection and unity is a
great deal to do with example and ideas
and leadership of those of you who
graduate today and that is what gives me
the confidence to deliver my charge to
you because after you depart for your
new destinations I want to ask you and I
hope some of you know what's coming I
want to ask you to
hug the world until you make the world a
little more like MIT more daring more
passionate more rigorous inventive and
ambitious more humble more respectful
more generous more kind this morning I
see 2,800 new graduates who are ready
for that cosmic problem set you made MIP
better and now you will make a better
world you came to MIT with exceptional
qualities of your own and now you leave
us equipped with a rare set of skills
and steeped in these communities deepest
values a commitment to excellence
integrity meritocracy baldness humidity
an open spirit of collaboration a strong
desire to make a positive impact in a
sense of responsibility to make the
world a better place and I also see a
planet that urgently needs everything
you have to offer so now go out there
join the world find your calling solve
the unsolvable invent the future take
the high road and you will continue to
make your family including your MIT
family proud on this wonderful day I'm
proud of all of you to every one of the
members of the graduating class of 2016
please accept my best wishes for a happy
and successful life and career
congratulations